you've heard us talk about it a jump in
deadly drunk driving crashes this year
like this one earlier this month
police telling us the driver of a rented
lamborghini was doing upwards of a
hundred
and forty miles an hour and he slammed
into a moped in russell in decatur
you saw a picture of the victim 58 year
old walter anderson and a memorial there
well the group called zero fatalities
has a new campaign
focusing on people who are not only
driving drunk but also driving
high andrew bennett from the nevada
department of public safety
joins us from exactly where that crash
happened first of all good morning
andrew thanks for being with us
good morning thank you for having me on
so tell me about this save yourself
campaign what's that all about
unfortunately as you said we have about
53 of our fatal crashes here in the
state of nevada
involve an impaired driver and we're all
too often seen a variety of substances
and that's why it was important for us
to focus on alcohol
and marijuana in this campaign and you
know looking behind me you can see the
cross and it doesn't take too many
streets
for you to be able to find one of these
roadside memorials and so we need to
raise awareness
so that we can have a safe summer to
make sure that everyone arrives home
safely at the end of each day
yeah one of the things that we talk
about a lot is people thinking oh i've
only had a drink or two so i'm okay
tell people why that's just not a good
idea
well this is the idea behind the
campaign of save yourself we want to
make
make sure that you have the opportunity
to make the right decisions
the designated driver needs to be the
one that hasn't been consuming anything
if you consume a substance that makes
you feel different you're going to drive
differently
and so whether it is marijuana alcohol
or combination of everything
we want to make sure that we have sober
designated drivers behind the wheel
that can get us home safely and you're
telling me about a a
an actual really targeted campaign
through the middle of august what are
the specifics of that
so the save yourself campaign we're
we're targeting specifically
people that are going to bars and people
are consuming marijuana
uh focusing on males 18 to 35
unfortunately that is the number one
demographic for
uh these crashes and this crash behind
me perfectly fit into that we have a
suspected impaired driver who was coming
into town rented a lamborghini
and as a result nevada and las vegas
lost a native
and so it's important for us that again
we get that message through have a great
time
we live in the greatest hit in the world
just make sure that you do it
responsibly
and get home safely and we were just
running some video of a psa looked like
there were some young adult men who were
kind of hanging out on a couch talking
about having a good time
and maybe driving or not driving and i
guess that's one of the main things
you're trying to get across is
don't take the keys if if you're
impaired in any way
exactly marijuana is legal here now and
it is an option
uh and you're you're legally allowed to
consume but as soon as you make that
decision to get behind the wheel
that could be fatal not only for you but
anybody on nevada's roadways
so please consume responsibility
responsibly and always drive sober
and uh we hope that you uh andrew folks
follow the
twitter accounts you guys have as
twitter called at
zero fatalities and you guys are always
working to get that message out
exactly zero fatalities envy on twitter
instagram and facebook
you know with these daily reminders in
these daily educations we just had a
legislative session with several law
changes
and so for more information you can go
there in our website which is zero
fatalities nv.com
awesome andrew from the nevada
department of public safety thank you so
much and keep up the good fight man